Being attractive is its own sort of prison.
What if we stopped offering thoughts and prayers...
...and instead offer prayers and thoughts?
For many years, we've watched TV, but now the TV watches us.
You have my permission to love.
My new motto for mental health:....
"Real eyes realize real lies."
Sit with that one for a minute.
It's hard to believe that ten years ago was just ten years ago.
So it's totally normal for a guy to be named Guy,...
...but weird for a girl to be named Girl.
For a freshwater creature, frogs are really cool.
Did you know that if you're young,...
...you haven't met most of the people who will attend your funeral?
If you drop a single tea leaf in the ocean,...
...the ocean becomes one very diluted tea.
I mean, at this point, why are they even called phones?
Did you know we spend all of our time watching the time...
...most of the time?
But what happens when we run out of time?